ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL BORDERS BRADFORD CAMBIADO
CHIANG DALLY DODD THAT ALSO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HELL WESSEL TADO
JACKSON JONES I SHOULD HAVE
LEYVA MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MONNING.
RIGHT WELL NIELSEN AYE PAN
POURTANT. RALPH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG Y. CASKEY WINNER
WILK. THANK YOU A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AT OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RATE IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LET
IMPROVE. IN SYSTEM BILL DORMAN
TO WHICH REMAINS WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR TO ROSS SO.
YEAH SO LET US BE CENTERED IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. THIS PLASTIC
THIS BLESSING IS FOR THE WOMEN
WHO NEED COURAGE AND MEN TO. I
CANNOT SAY HER COURAGE LIVES.
THAT IT COMES TO THE HEART THAT
IS OPEN TO THE HEART THAT ASKS
TO THE HEART THE TO TURN AWAY.
CAN TAKE PRACTICE DAYS OF
TARGETING IS WHAT KEEPS US
BONES SEASONS OF PUSHING
AGAINST WHAT KEEPS ARE DREAMING
SMALL. WHEN IT ARRIVES IT MIGHT
SURPRISE US BY HOW QUIET IT IS.
BUT WE WILL KNOW IT'S BY THE
STRENGTH THAT ARISES FROM
WITHIN. WE WILL RECOGNIZE THE
BY HOUSE STILL OUR FEAR BECOMES
PERHAPS NEVER QUITE LEAVING BUT
CALMLY TURNING INTO JOY AS WE
ENTER THE LIFE THAT IS FINALLY
ARE OPEN. BRITISH SCUDS FOR THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE INSPIRED US TO
GREATER COURAGE IN OUR LIVES A
MAN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
SALUTE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG THE- FOR. AS IS
AVAILABLE.
TO GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE IN DREAD REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. OUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
WHICH NINE THROUGH MARCH
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. PURSUANT TO
CENTER TWENTY NINE TEN SEE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE FILE ITEM
ONE AB. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR.
CONSIDER OPTION OF THE DAILY
FILE US WE'LL START WITH THE
SECOND READING FOUND MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR THE SECOND
READING I WILL BE DEEMED READ
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS ITEM TO
END FOR SENATOR ATKINS. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM TWO IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF CAROLYN SIEGEL
SAYING TO THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION MISS
SINGLE SAYING SERVICES A
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
COMMISSION AND SHE CURRENTLY IS
ATTENDING THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA. GO I PROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR CODE CALLING.
THANK MAYOR PRO TEM IN ANY
DISCUSSION ORDER EIGHT. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES NOBEL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD.
CAMBIADO HI CHIANG. DALLY DODD.
THAT ALSO HI GALGIANI. GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ. GROVE HERTZBERG I
HILL. WES SO TADA HI JACKSON
AYE JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL HI MONNING. MORE
LOCK MORRELL. NO NIELSEN. PAN
HI PORTANTINO HI ROSS I RUBIO.
I SKINNER. STERN HI AMBERG FIVE
Y. CASKEY HI WIENER. WILK.
SENATOR MOVE A FILE ITEM FOR
SENATOR ATKINS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM FOR IS A
CONFIRMATION OF SAMANTHA MURRAY
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE GAME
MISSION MISS MERRY IS AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND FACULTY
THE SCRIPT TO TOOT OF OCEAN. AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN DIEGO OBVIOUS A SAN DIEGO
DAY. SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SIX ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE CALLS I RESPECTFULLY
TO YOUR AYE THOSE. TIM MEMBERS
IN NEED. OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
PARTULA AYE ATKINS HI BATES HI
BEL HI BORDERS. BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DELHI
CHENNAI DELHI. DODD THEY'RE
ALSO HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. GROVE HI HERTZBERG HI
HI HILL HI WAS OF. R. TADO HI
JACKSON HI JONES. LABOR JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
HI MONNING. MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN HI PAN HI PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER.
STERN AYE AMBERG HI MY CASKEY
HI WIENER HI WILK HI GORGEOUS I.
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
WE REVIEWED MOVING TO SENATE
THIRD READING WE HAVE ONE ITEM
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN CENTER
CHIANG MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR CHIANG RELATIVE TO
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND STEM LIKE
SENATOR CHIANG THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AS WE
CELEBRATE WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH
UNDER TO BRING USC ARE EIGHTY
FIVE A RESOLUTION TO
COMMEMORATE WHEN WAS IN SAM
WEEK. TOPPING GROUP IN SCIENCE
THE ENGINE. KERN HIGH AND BUT
IT IS OFTEN TO FOR ME. TO FOR
THESE JOBS. MEMBERS WE HAVE TWO
BIG ISSUES HERE LAYERED ON TOP
OF EACH OTHER. WE HAVE A
STANDSTILL GAP CROSS COUNTRY
AND AMONG THOSE PARTICIPATING
IN ST THERE EXISTS A SERIES
GENDER INEQUITY. WELL WE HAVE
MADE PROGRESS WOMEN CONTINUE TO
BE AN UNDER REPRESENTS THEM
FIELD. WOMEN REPRESENT ONLY A
QUARTER OF THE STEM WORKFORCE.
WOMEN ARE HALF THE POPULATION
IN INCREASINGLY MAJORITY
COLLEGE. BY TAPPING THE GENDER
DISPARITY IN STAND WITH HELP
FILL THE SKILLS GAP ALL OF US
CAN BE PART OF THE SOLUTION BY
ENCOURAGING THE YOUNG WOMEN IN
OUR LIVES TO CONTINUE THEIR
WORK IN. THEM MY- THAT DESPITE
UNDER A- IN THE STEM. TODAY'S
LEADERS IN STAND STAND ON THE
SHOULDERS OF FEMALE INNOVATORS
THAT CAME BEFORE THEM. MISTER
MAYER AND EXPERT PETER SCIENCE
AND ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE SHE
WAS GOOGLE'S FIRST EMPLOYEE
WHERE SHE WROTE CODE AND
OVERSIGHT TEAMS OF ENGINEERS
BOWSTREET COMPANIES SEARCH AND
THEN- AND SHE WAS ALSO THE CEO
OF YAHOO FOR SIX YEARS. MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN MISSING MYERS ARE OUT
THERE RIGHT NOW WHO DIDN'T
FINEST THEM OUT WHAT. WE CAN
AND NEED TO DO BETTER AS HE
ALREADY FIVE CREATES A PLATFORM
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS
IMPORTANT EFFORT PUTTING
CALIFORNIA. MEANING GIRLS AND
STEM WEEK. THANK YOU CENTER
CHIANG MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OUT I ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS HI
BATES I TELL HI PORCHES HI
BRADFORD CAMBIADO HI CHIANG I
DALY. DODD THEY'RE ALSO HI
GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
GROVE HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI
PUESTO TADA HI JACKSON HI JONES.
HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL HI MONNING. MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH HIGH MORALE AYE
NIELSEN HI PAN HI PORTANTINO HI
FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO HI SKINNER.
STERN HI AMBERG HI Y. CASKEY
FIVE WIENER AYE WILK I. SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE HAVE ONE ITEM FILE
ITEM SIXTY ONE SENATOR NIELSEN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA KIDNEY DAY SENATOR
NIELSEN. THAT APRESENT LADIES
AND DEVON THE SENATE THIS
RESOLUTION WILL ALLOW COMMEND
TODAY AS CAL FOR A CHRONIC
KIDNEY DISEASE DAY. IT'S AN
AFFLICTION THAT'S BEEN AROUND A
LONG TIME BUT LACKEY IS NOT
BEEN SUFFICIENTLY RECOGNIZED.
WE HAD A VERY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT WITH THE
MEMBER. STAFF ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES- FROM- LAFAYETTE HAD
WORKED WITH OVER THE YEARS WE
BATTLED IT FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS VERY COURAGEOUSLY MISTER
STEVE THAT WAS HIS NAME. SO
WE'VE HAD ONE OF OURS OF
FLITTED. IT'S WELL THAT WHEN WE
RECOGNIZE THESE DAYS THAT IT
BRINGS FORTH A GREATER
AWARENESS AMONG SOCIETY IN
AMERICA. OF THESE THINGS THAT
MAYBE HAVE NOT OUR LIVES BUT
THAT CAN THROUGH THE
COMMUNICATION AND A KNOWLEDGE
MEANT OF SUCH A DAY. WE'RE ALL
SO IT PASSED THE HEAD. SEARCH
THE APPLET PEOPLE BEING AWARE
OF EARLY STAGES OF THESE
AFFLICTION AND HELP US GET IT
MORE UNDER CONTROL. WITHOUT AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
NIELSEN DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU I MATTER
PRESENCE SITES I IS IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE SIXTY EIGHT AND UP
ONE OF. THE CITY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. WHAT'S ALL THE VITAL
THINGS- A KIDNEY DOES AND SO
WHEN YOU HAVE KIDNEY DISEASE.
THE PERSON'S BODY- SOMETIMES
PEOPLE LIKE TO TALK THE TALK.
YOUR KIDNEYS YOUR NATURAL
DETOX. IT TAKES THE OUTSIDE
TAKES THE THINGS FROM YOUR
BLOOD AND THEN THE HELPS FILTER
THAT OUT BUT- SO THE THINGS
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE IS FOR
EXAMPLE YOUR KIDNEY ACT TO
CONTROL YOUR BLOOD- WAS A VITAL
PART OF CONTROLLING PRESSURE.
ALSO WHEN YOU HAVE TO. A DIET
AS WELL THIS THAT'S A- I ALSO
YOUR KIDNEYS. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE BRITTANY
HEALTHY BUT ALL THAT WE- ALSO.
THAT WHEN KIDNEYS FAILED. NO
CURE BASICALLY WE TRIED EITHER-
HANDLE ARTIFICIALLY TO DIE ALL.
PLAN IT'S THROUGH WE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE TRY TO
KEEP YOUR KIDNEYS HEALTHY AT A
PRE. THE RAISING AWARENESS OF.
HEALTH THROUGH CAP. A VIRGIN
THANK YOU. YOU MEMBERS FURTHER
ACTION OR TO. SEEING NONE SO
WILSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL.
BACK CASTING DIET VERY SUBJECT
MATTER THANK YOU SO NIELSEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI. AYE
BATES AYE BELL. FIVE LARGEST HI
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG HI
SALLY. DODD I DID ALSO HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ
GROVE HI HERTZBERG HI HILL I
WAS SO TADA HI JACKSON. I JONES
HI LEYVA. AYE MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL HI MONNING. MORE LOCK
HIGH MORALE HI NIELSEN AYE PAN.
HI PORTANTINO HI ROSS. HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI Y. CASKEY. HI WIENER AYE
WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD DALY GONZALEZ
WEST OF MORNING SKINNER. BY
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATE ALLEN MEMBERS I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MEANT TO
INTRODUCE SOME WONDERFUL FOLKS
FROM MY DISTRICT YOU'RE HERE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR I WANT TO ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
ANTHONY GARDNER SURE PERSON
REALLY. RANKED UP IN TWENTY
BASKET. TRICIA ROB. SANTA
MONICA. I'D INCLUDE MY GOOD
FRIEND MEDI YEAH WHO IS- WE
SERVE TOGETHER ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD SANTA MONICA MALIBU SHE
ALSO WORKS AT THE COLLEGE
THEY'RE HERE. IN FACT TODAY FOR
THE- CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ASSOCIATION
OCCUPATIONAL EDUC CAN.
CONFERENCE WE JUST GIVE A VERY
WARM SO. WELCOME AND WELCOME TO
YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THE MEMBERS FROM MY
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT MARSTON
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
DIRECTOR GINGER ON TOMORROW'S
AND THREE OF THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS FROM SAN MARINO HIGH
SCHOOL WELCOME SO HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU IN. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
GOING TO LIFT CALLS ON THE ON
CALL ITEMS THE FIRST IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI BEL HI
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CHIANG DALLY
DODD I GALGIANI I GONZALEZ
GROVE NO HILL. I WAS SO. MON
AND- MORE LOCK. NIELSEN SKINNER
WINNER I WILK. I TWENTY FOUR
KNOWS FOR THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HI BRADFORD DALY. DODD
GONZALEZ DODD AYE GONZALEZ.
WEST OF. MONNING MORE LOCK.
HIGH MORALE. HIGH SKINNER. EYES
THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD DALLY. DODD HI
GONZALEZ WES SO MONNING SKINNER.
I WAS THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. VERY
GOOD MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON
TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS IF
YOU HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT
A COMMITTEE THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THE WHITE
HOUSE SKI A MADAM PRESIDENT HE
TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW.
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING FIVE
MINUTES APART ADJOURNMENT THANK
YOU SENATOR WHITE HOUSE THESE
SENATOR ROTH. THINK ABOUT
PRESIDENT THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATION WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE A
MEASLY ON GERMAN THANK YOU
SENATOR ROBB CENTER PAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE BUT
SENATE BY FISCAL SUB. NUMBER
WILL BE HOLDING ITS HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE- TEN
MINUTES AFTER GERMAN OUT SO
MAKE NOTE THAT WE WILL ALSO BE
HERE THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC.
THE OF HEALTH AS WELL AS
HEARING TODAY THANK YOU THE-
THIRD UMPIRE. THANK YOU OF
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW SEPT
WILL BE MEETING. THE GERMAN TO.
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THANK YOU
CENTER CABALLERO MEMBERS WE ARE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR JOURNEYMEN
REYES SENATOR ATKINS.
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU. I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF RICHARD
LEO MASCARA. RICHARD PASSED
AWAY LAST WEEK ON MARCH FIFTH
AT THE INCREDIBLY YOUNG AGE OF
THIRTY FOUR AFTER A LENGTHY
BATTLE WITH CANCER. I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD FIND OUT HIS FAMILY IS
OVER HERE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
STAND ARE JOINING US TODAY AS I
READ. I REMARKED OUT RICHARD.
MOST RECENTLY HE WORKED AT THE
OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
AS A DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL. RICHARD SPENT HIS
EARLIEST YEARS IN PITTSBURGH
BEFORE HIS FAMILY RELOCATED TO
THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA WHERE
HE ATTENDED WESTLAKE SCHOOL.
SCIENCE TEACHERS- THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AS A SUMMER
INTERN IN TWENTY TWELVE AND
THEN RETURN TO THE OFFICE AS A
DEPUTY IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AFTER
HIS LAW THE- HEALTH. STERN LAW
IN SAN DIEGO. LET COUNTY RICH.
DRESS LEGISLATION AREAS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CRIMINAL LAW AND
THE VEHICLE CODE WERE EXEMPLARY.
THE LAST FOUR YEARS IN OFFICE
RE WORKED IN THE OPINION BRANCH
PROVIDING EXCELLENT WELL
CRAFTED- WRITTEN OPINIONS FOR
MEMBERS FOR US AND HALF OF THE
LOOK LATER ON A VARIETY OF
TOPICS HE WAS A PER OF AN
ORDINARY CARE WAS WELL REGARDED.
IS LEGAL AT MEN AS WELL AS A
WRY SENSE OF HUMOR. GOOD
NATURED HEARTED AND CHERISHED A
CHERISHED FRIEND WHO HAD A
SPECIAL CAPACITY FOR LISTENING
A MAKING FEEL BETTER HE LOVES
TRAVELING SPENDING TIME WITH
HIS BELOVED MARY A LABRADOR MIX
HE RESCUE. FALLEN LAW SCHOOL
THEM LINK SOLVE PUZZLES IN
BAGHDAD. EATING DELICIOUS FOODS
PARTICULARLY HIS DAD'S
TRADITIONAL ITALIAN COOKING.
JOINT IN OF CHAMBERS TODAY IS
THIRDS BELOVED FAMILY HIS
HUSBAND WILLIAM MCRAE HIS
FATHER RICHARD HIS CANDY HIS
SISTER MAGGIE AND OF COURSE OUR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL EMPLOYER
NINE. COLLEAGUES I WOULD ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN A JOURNEYING
IN MEMORY. LEO MAC. IF THANK
YOU CENTER AT. WELCOME TO THE
FAMILY THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
WE'RE SORRY WE'RE HERE IT'S
SUCH A SAD OCCASION PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE. WOULD REQUEST THAT
WE HONOR ONE OF OUR OWN. ROSA
GARY ROSALYN A GARY ASKED WAY
MARCH THIRD AT THE UC DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER. THE THIRTY TWO
YEAR EMPLOYEE HERE OF THE
SENATE SERVING US NOTABLY OVER
THOSE MANY MANY YEARS IN MANY
WAYS IN MANY CAPACITIES. SHE
WAS BORN IN TEXAS TO MERION
DAVID A GEHRY. CAME TO FORTY
ACT AND FASHIONED A WONDERFUL
CAREER. HERE IN THIS
INSTITUTION BEING INTEGRAL
THOUGH OFTEN UNRECOGNIZED
BEHIND THE SCENES DOING THE JOB
THAT ALLOWED THE MEMBERS DO SO
EFFECTIVELY. DO OUR JOBS. SHE
HAD A PARTNER FOR FIFTY ONE
YEARS. PATRICIA EMERSON. ALSO
PART OF OUR SENATE FAMILY. WE
HAVE EXTEND OUR HEARTS TO THAT
FAMILY. WITH OUR HEARTFELT
THANKS. TWO ROWS TAKEN FROM US
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT TOO SOON.
BUT HER PRESENCE WILL ALWAYS BE
HERE EVEN TO THE UNKNOWN IN
FUTURE WE WILL NEVER EVER KNOW
HER NAME. BUT SHE CONTRIBUTED
TO THE GREATNESS OF THIS SINCE
XIN. SEVERAL THE GEAR. THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN PLEASE BRING
HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO
SADLY JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF
GUNNERY SERGEANT DIEGO PONGO.
ONE OF TWO MARINES KILLED IN
ACTION LAST SUNDAY WHILE
CLEARING A TUNNEL COMPLEX IN
ISIS STRONGHOLD IN NORTH
CENTRAL IRAQ. GUNNERY SERGEANT
PONGO BEGAN HIS DECADE AND A
HALF OF ILLUSTRIOUS SERVICE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. AND LISTING
AS IN THREE ELEVEN RIFLEMAN IN
THE MARINE CORPS. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. THE SCOUT SNIPER BASIC
COURSE AND SUBSEQUENTLY
DEPLOYED AFGHANISTAN AS A
SNIPER TEAM LEADER WITH FIRST
BATTALION FIFTH MARINES. AND
BECAME A MARINE GREATER IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WE COMPLETED
DEPLOYMENTS TO IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN MOST RECENTLY WAS
SECOND RING RATED MARINE RAIDER
BATTALION MARINE FORCES SPECIAL
COMMAND SPECIAL OPERATIONS
COMMAND- IN IN AFGHANISTAN HE-
BOTH THE BRONZE OUR- I WITH THE
CAR AT THIS KING DEVICE FOR
VALOR A PURPLE HEART. TWO NAVY
INNER CORE COMMENDATION MEDALS.
A NAVY AND MARINE CORPS
ACHIEVEMENT MEDAL AND TO COMBAT
ACTION RIBBONS BUT HE WASN'T
DONE ACHIEVING HE THEN GOT
DEPLOYED TO IRAQ. A FOR
OPERATION INHERENT RESOLVE
WHERE HE IN HIS FIFTY TWO
REMAINING SOLDIERS WERE THERE
TO THIS DAY. WHEN YOU MIGHT
GATHER FROM HIS EXAMPLE OUR
RECORD LONG LIST OF DECK TENS
IS THAT GONNA RESURGENT PONGO
WHAT YOUR NEAR THREE IS. IT
OIL. IN MEN. A COMBAT MORE THAN.
AND AS HIS FELLOW MARINES ARE
SAID IN RECENT DAYS DESPITE ALL
HIS ACHIEVEMENTS GUNNERY
SERGEANT POPPING GO BALANCED
HIS LARGER THAN LIFE PERSON AT.
WITH A UNIQUE SENSE OF HUMILITY.
HIS LOSS IS DEEPLY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. HE HAILS FROM SEAMY
VALLEY AND HAVING GONE TO
VALLEY VIEW MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
SEAMY VALLEY HIGH. AND TAKING
CLASSES MOORPARK COLLEGE HE
WAS- LOCAL BOY DONE GOOD FOR
THE GALLERIES. HAD SO MUCH LEFT
TO DO IN HIS LIFE AND SO MUCH
TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND OUR NATION WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THIS EXTRAORDINARY LIFE.
WAS SPENT WELL. AND THAT SEAMY
VALLEY AND OUR NATION WILL BE
MADE BETTER BY HIS LEADERSHIP.
FOR AN EXTRAORDINARY. AND
DEDICATION TO THIS NATION HE
WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN. AND HE
IS SURVIVED IS DAUGHTER IN HIS
PARENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE INSURE. IN HIS MEMORY
AND OFFER OUR SINCEREST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING HIM IN FOR ITS.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES- TODAY I SAID
THE RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF JOE COLUMN BY THE OF.
THOSE WHO PASSED AWAY AT THE
AGE NINETY HIS HOME AND PASSED
THE- JOE WAS A RETAIL. WHO
FOUNDED THE IN ALL TRADER JOE'S
GROCERIES. AND WHAT WANT TO BE
CAUGHT FOOD WINE. AND PAINTER
AND SOUTHERN CAL FALLING. BORN
JUNE TH AND THIRTY JOE RAISED
ON A RANCH AND MAR HE SERVED A
YEAR AND AIR FOR. AND GOT A
BACK TO IN AT. FOR BY NAY A FOR
BAND DINNER IN NINETEEN FOUR.
JOE IN A NEW BROCHURE. NEW
JENNA OF GROW SHOP EMERGING IN
SIX. HEALTH HE QUALITY I
COULDN'T FIND IT SHOULD MARKETS
AND COULD AFFORD TO BUY IN A
FEW HIGH END GOURMET OUT OPENED
ITS FIRST STORE PASS. IN
NINETEEN SIX SEVEN UNTIL HIS
DEATH JOE WATCH HIS. IT'S RISE
FROM A FAVORITE OF UNDERPAID
HIPPIES TO A RETAIL WITH MORE
THE FIVE HOW IN OVER FOR STATE.
AFTER CELL TRADER. TO AGREE A
GERMAN RE IN NINETEEN NINE JOE
REMAIN THE G. COULD'VE UNTIL
EIGHTY WHEN HE LEFT TO LAUNCH A
SECOND CAREER AS WHAT HE A TWO.
COMING IN AS AN INTERIM CEO CEO
OR ON SEVERAL LARGE BENEATH.
THEY WERE TO. THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
YEAR JOE SO NUMBER OF COURT FOR
INCLUDING IN BANK BECAUSE PLUS
WORLD BRISTOL FARMS AND TRUE
RELIGION JEANS. HE WORKS THAT
ONLY A OVER FROM THE BOARD COST
PLUS AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND
THERE. HE WAS. IN LANCE PETER
BUT THE OF THE IN LAW ARE EIGHT
THE COLBERT SCHOOL AND A LOT
ANGELES. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
OUR DEAR WHO. IN NINETEEN. AND
HISSED CHORE IS ME IN ADDRESS.
HAVE TRADER JOE THANK YOU SENT
PORTANTINO PLEA BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD TO CAN BE PROP MORE.
SENATOR CHILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PRESIDENT IT'S TO SIT HERE
AND TO THE GERMAN MEMBER WILL
BURN. ABOUT FELLER CUT. DURING
JUST THE DIVERSE FOR. VERY
YOUNG WHO WE'VE LAW TO SEE TO
BE WHO LIVE FOR A LOT SO. I'D
LIKE TO ADD. THE NAME FOR THE
RECORD TODAY A CAL. AN A TRUE
CARE IF YOU KNOW IT WAS JAMES
SOME. AND MORNING FOR. THIS
GROUP I'M REALLY IN SO DO YOU
KNOW IT WAS THAT DEVELOPED
CALLED PERSONAL TO MANY FOR IS
CHURCH WE NUMBER MATER YOU SEE
RIVER. KLAY CITY COUNCIL I KNOW
MY OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
WHAT. THE SHE IF YOU WERE HERE
NEWS STORIES ABOUT- SWEENEY'S
COMMITMENT TO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN BERKELEY
HOW HARD WORK- TO MAKE SURE
THAT RED LINING WAS A THING
PASSED OUT IN ISSUE CAN YOU.
WHAT AND A RED. THE CITY. AFTER
HIS SIX TENURE AT A CITY
COUNCIL AND JAMES BROUGHT HIS
TOWN THANK SERVING AS A LOT AN
EARLY AGE FOR NEW ORGAN
PRIMARILY CIVIL RIGHTS AT THE
TO SEE ORGANIZATION OF WHO DO
WORK THE CAPITAL. ROARING LAUGH
OF THE ACROSS THIS AT IN ST
WOULDN'T IT WOULDN'T THINK TO
ABOUT. OUT MY NAME ACROSS THE
STREET JUST TO MAKE SURE I SAW
HIM IN COULD COME ACROSS THE
STREET GIVE HIM A BIG. WE WILL
NEVER. IS ADVOCACY HIS WORK ON
BEHALF OF IN THE ACP THE
CHAMBER MANY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENT THE AFTER AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
ACROSS EIGHT. WE DAY AGAIN
JAMES SWING. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR PAN ON SOJOURN
YES THING YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
RICE IN MEMORY OF THE JAMES.
WHO'S A CONCERT MY DE AND I ONE
THING MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
WHICH HER PERSONAL RECORD.
SWEENEY YOUR MISSED THE WORST
THE TERM THIS MAY AND ACTIVISTS
TOO MANY HERE AND TELL HE
WORKED IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
OTHER AS A LAY. THE TO THE CAL.
OF EIGHT AND THEY ALSO SERVE AS
A MEMBER OF THE COUNCIL ON MEN
ILL IF. A TO MISS OF THE FOR
GOV. SO HE CERTAINLY BE GREATLY
MISSED BY BY. ALL OF US AND
AGAIN I TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MAP. OF THE WONDERFUL
LIFE. OF MR J. SWEENEY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR IMAGE OF
THE BRING HIS NAME FOR ITS CAN
BE PROUD MOM. MEMBERS IF THERE
IS NO FURTHER BUSINESS. MADAM
PRO TEM THAT'S BECAUSE- I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CALLING I
ONE OF MAKE TO A FEW COMMENTS
OF BRIEF. I THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO MONITOR THE
CORONAVIRUS MISSION AS IT OF
ALL. WE HAD MEETINGS THIS ISSUE
TO UPDATE OUR ALL OF YOU IN
ADDITION TO PER IN THE HEALTH
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT CAL.
APPROACH THE SITUATION WITH
CLARITY AND CALL. AS YOU HEARD
CAL PUBLIC OFFICIALS HAVE
ISSUED UPDATE POLICY ON CERTAIN
GATHERINGS. POSTPONED CANCELED
UNTIL AT LEAST THE END OF MARCH
THEIR GUIDANCE AFFECTS
NONESSENTIAL NONESSENTIAL LARGE
GATHERINGS SMALL GATHERINGS
WERE SPACE FOR SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS ON. VETERANS OF
END WHO ARE AT HIGHER. FOR
SEVERE ILLNESS FROM THE CORONA
VIRUS. AS I JOIN THE GOVERNOR
AND URGE CALIFORNIANS TO FOLLOW
THIS UPDATED POLICY I'M ALSO A
OF HIM IT HAS ON OUR OWN WORK.
THOSE OF. ARE FOR THE BAD WHICH
TO ROOM LET. IS NOT AN OPTION
AT THIS TIME. BUT WE WILL BE
TAKING THE NEXT FEW DAYS TO DO
A HARD EVALUATION OF HOW TO
PROCEED WITH IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH PARAMETERS. WERE TO WORK
THE GIRL. AND THE ASSEMBLY TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO ASSESS
WORKER. SMALL AND FAMILIES WHO
FIND THEMSELVES HARMED
ECONOMICALLY BY ASSIST OUR
EFFORTS TO MITIGATE THE CORONA
VIRUS. NO ONE TO PAY A PRICE
FOR DOING THE RIGHT THING AND
PROTECTING THE LIVES AND THE
HEALTH OF OTHERS. I PERSONALLY
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE I OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE SECRETARY
OF THE SENATE WHO OBVIOUSLY IS
BUSY DOING THE WORK. AROUND THE
CLOCK I ASSURE YOU TO REVIEW IN
PLAN FOR HOW TO BET DOCTOR ARE
CRITICAL PUBLIC GEN. AS WE
DEVELOP THE PATH FORWARD
CONTINUE WORKING TO A US RISK.
AND A COMMON THE VIN THE WAY
SHE- WE WILL BE SURE RESOURCE
ANNOUNED BY BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IF CAN ANYA VIA THE
WEB ARE ALL. TO SAY HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK IS A
GOOD. OFFICE OF A AND C.
SERVICES THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT WHO ARE
WORKING TO KEEP US ALL INFORMED
AS QUICKLY. AS THEY WILL TO DO
THAT. SO CAN YOU TO ROUTE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CAPITAL
THROUGH MY OFFICE OR THE
SECRETARY GOD THE SECRETARY'S
OFFICE AND LET ME JUST HERE.
COLLEAGUES RUMORS NOT HELP IF
YOU GET A PIECE OF INFORMATION
YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT PLEASE
CALL THE SECRETARY OFFICE FOR
MY OFFICE. AND LET. GIVE YOU
THE ACT. MAISCH WE ARE. TO AIR.
COM EVERY IS BUT WE TO DO IT A
PRO. SO I WOULD ASK PLEASE
SPREAD ROOM. CALL THE OFF IF
YOU SOME CONCERNED ABOUT AND
LET US IT DOWN TRACKING DOWN
AND REACT AND WE'RE TO. I WANT
TO THANK FOR THAT SUGGESTION
SENATOR FINALLY WANT TO EXPRESS
GRATITUDE TO EVERY SINGLE ONE
SINGLE HAVE YOU FOR TOGETHER IS
TALKING. TO WORK IT. THANK
WELL. OUR CAN. OUR STATE. AND
ARE FAMILIES AND OF ALL OF OUR-
THE CITY REMAINS VERY SEE AND
IT RE VERY FLUID IT IS NOT ANY
OF US WOULD HOPE TO BUT IS
CERTAINLY THE CHAO WILL AS WELL
NOW AND I AM SIR THAT WE ROCK
TO THE TO THE CHURCH MUCH AND
TO THIS. BEEN IN A THAT IS A
PRO. AND IT TAKES THE- CERTAIN
THE FOR. RED CROSS ON SAID YOU
MUST SO MUCH THANK AS WHETHER
YOU LIKE IT OR WHETHER IT IS
BARE OR NOT YOU MIGHT NEVER
THINK OF ANY EXT THE NEED AND
HOW THE MEDIA. COLLEAGUES I
HOPE YOU HAVE A GOOD WEEK. WITH
YOUR FAMILIES AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TAKE THE REST THAT
YOU NEED NOW MORE THAN EVER TO
GET THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
RED TO BE ABLE TO TACKLE THESE
CHALLENGES. BUT WE NEED. A B.
U. R. DAY MARKS. TWENTY TWO AT.
MADAME FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAN APPROACH. MEMBER THE SENATE
WILL RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
I'M THE JERK BROCHURE TO BE
MADE WE RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND MEMBERS.